illuminated buildings experimental art
sculptures of light luminol emerges
these three concepts into one the light
festival takes place every two years in
Frankfurt coinciding with the world's
largest trade fair for lighting and
building but it's not just a showcase
for industry specialists the spectacle
is a huge hit with tourists and locals
for six days and nights Frankfurt is
awash with the light of 182
installations it's marvelous to wander
from place to place in the spring
weather but instead of using the Stars
to navigate we're using the illuminated
objects with light you can represent so
many different things I mean it can
literally drive you in imagination into
so many different directions Lou manali
aims to be a laboratory for experiments
in light and this year the round side
Parvati nor space-time pirates embody
that spirit of innovation like no other
project it's a collective of cologne
based artists Moritz élevage Tobias
Damien and yan aylen they've been
collaborating since 2007 and their
installations and performances can be
seen at festivals across Europe come on
the phone once we started taking an
interest in machines like old projectors
it's a platonic identity and we started
taking them apart modifying them that's
named sue bones and that's when we
discovered our love for optical
equipment tisha cadets often their
methods are part of what makes them
special
the space-time pirates don't use
ready-made ideas they set up everything
on site like here in front foot yaba
admit we work with fittings and lab
equipment that is easy to put together
ma that means you can set up the
installations and individual elements of
the instruments wherever you are I'm
vanilla mint a dense and you can also
fit everything to whatever space you
have available dementia patient I'll to
nandanam and pass and come those
instruments are a combination of optical
and acoustic systems the three also
carry a bag full of technical equipment
wherever they go would institutions will
co-founders the case that we pack
everything into we use it to transport
all the equipment that will be used in
our installations incidents will run by
the dolls are wiping some of the
installations are so small they can fit
in a suitcase that's practical for
visits to festivals especially when they
travel further afield a performance is
never complete for these three artists
throughout the show they're constantly
trying new things that's exactly what
the lumen ollies artistic director at
hemet beam wants to see
yeah and that's not angry we are
witnessing the digitalization of light
one used to turn light on and off now
it's all about creating entire scenarios
for us artists what is interesting is
putting on performances with life
performances Smith leaked once so it's a
Zayn given the range of projects at the
festival is huge shadow theater
projected at the top of a skyscraper
performed by actor Julian button down
below the audience is invited to join in
the light object Twinkle Twinkle is made
of hundreds of glass prism poles a
sparkling vortex that changes all the
time the refractions create a
fascinating color spectrum at luminol a
you can enjoy all the art and also learn
about innovations in lighting technology
it's exciting for the space-time pirates
two moments in vicia antosy are very
interested in recent developments LEDs
and lasers they use less and less
electricity and are getting smaller and
smaller denso phenoxy and that means
it's easier for us to experiment and to
invent and construct our own devices
coveted surfeit notes about new
technology means new artistic
opportunities one constant in the
fast-changing world of light art is the
fascination with light end with shadow
you